[Música]
llegamos para hablar de revista de
prensa en directo américa de france 24 y
viernes ya terminamos semana rosa pérez
más de eeuu y abrimos esta revista de
prensa con un análisis del medio al
yazira que en el marco de la gira del
presidente estadounidense joe biden por
medio oriente compartió la política
perdón compara o mejor dicho la política
actual del presidente de joe biden
respecto a su predecesor donald trump
que encontramos en este artículo rosa
buenos días raúl pues este artículo
empieza diciendo que bien es conocido
que joe biden el actual presidente de
eeuu es un autoproclamado sionista por
lo que las personas que abogan por los
derechos humanos o los derechos de la
población palestina no tenían una fe
especial en que su mandato mejorará
particularmente la vida de la población
palestina sin embargo esperarán que
revocara algunas de las medidas
adoptadas como bien decías por su
antecesor donald trump por ejemplo que
volviera a trasladar la embajada de eeuu
en israel a tel aviv porque recordemos
que donald trump la movió en 2018 a
jerusalén por otro que reabriera el
consulado para los asuntos palestinos en
jerusalén este algo que de momento no va
a suceder por otro lado dice es cierto
que byd en a diferencia de trump se ha
opuesto a la ampliación de las colonias
o de los asentamientos israelíes a
judíos en los territorios palestinos
ocupados pero al yazira lamenta que sin
embargo la administración baiden
continúe haciendo uso de este lenguaje
que equipara a la bando israelí con el
bando palestino como si no estuviera
claramente diferenciado el ocupante del
ocupado por otro lado recordemos que
ayer biden en una rueda de prensa con
yair lapid el primer ministro en
funciones de israel también rechazó la
terminología de apartheid para hacer
referencia al régimen político en israel
respecto a la población palestina y de
hecho un portavoz de la arap american
institute señala en este texto que a
israel se le permiten abusos de los
derechos humanos sin consecuencias
gracias a la impunidad que le permite su
importante alianza con eeuu también que
bardem se levanta de ser presidente
estado estadounidense que ha pasado un
mayor paquete de ayuda a israel de ayuda
financiera pero que por otro lado hay
que destacar también que revivió la
ayuda a palestina que donald trump había
suprimido eso sí es prácticamente una
décima parte la ayuda financiera que se
ayuda a palestina que se envía a
palestina respecto a la que se envía a
israel por otro lado también señala que
byd en continuar con la normalización de
las relaciones entre israel y los países
árabes de su alrededor los llamados
acuerdos de abraham que promovió donald
trump y que se opone a que la corte
penal internacional investigue las
violaciones de derechos humanos
supuestamente cometidas por israel
contra la población palestina
particularmente se opuso a que sea la
corte penal internacional la que
investigue el asesinato de la periodista
de al yazira chili nabo aquel que
recordemos al yazira digamos atribuye
esta estaba la que la mató directamente
a las fuerzas israelís así como también
lo ha hecho la investigación de naciones
unidas y para
sí que es verdad que biden aboga
repetidamente lo ha declarado por una
solución que pase por la creación de dos
estados es decir la creación también de
un estado palestino sin embargo no ha
acabado nunca de especificar una hoja de
ruta clara para que esto suceda al menos
que se den pasos hacia estos dos estados
bajo su mandato
rosa continuamos con una gira de vaivén
porque una etapa ha sido particularmente
criticada por supuesto el encuentro que
va a tener by tim con bin salman en
arabia saudita luego de criticar a este
país y decir que el príncipe heredero
digamos era un asesino mejor dicho
también todo el estado toda la monarquía
de riad por el asesinato de yamaha shock
sí exactamente y una de las personas
como veíamos en el noticiero que lo ha
criticado abiertamente es la que era la
prometida del periodista jairo vino
antes de que éste fuera asesinato
recordemos en la embajada de arabia
saudí turquía bien básicamente en un
artículo del washington post como decías
bádenas
defiende de las acusaciones de las
críticas que ha recibido
particularmente por esta parada en
arabia saudita en esta gira por medio
oriente y básicamente hay un párrafo que
resume sus argumentos y estos argumentos
son básicamente que necesita más que
nada los aliados en esta región en medio
oriente para hacer frente a la coyuntura
actual a los impactos de la invasión
rusa en ucrania y para poder digamos
impedir que china le sobrepase como
potencia mundial te leo rápidamente él
es leo este párrafo dice un medio
oriente más seguro e integrado beneficia
a eeuu de muchas maneras sus vías
marítimas son esenciales para el
comercio mundial y las cadenas de
suministro de las que dependemos sus
recursos energéticos son vitales para
mitigar el impacto en los suministros
globales de la guerra rus de rusia en
ucrania y en una región unida mediante
la diplomacia hay menos probabilidades
que crezca el extremismo violento que
amenaza a nuestra patria o que surjan
nuevas guerras que suponen una carga
para el ejército de eeuu
de los militares y respecto a arabia
saudí en particular dice que su objetivo
siempre fue reorientar pero no romper
las relaciones con un socio estratégico
como bien decías deja de llamarle estado
pare ahí lo vuelva a llamar socio
estratégico rosa cerramos esta semana
con un tema bien distinto porque la
revista 'time' propone los 50 mejores de
destinaciones digamos para ir a
vacacionar del mundo si es una lista
como bien decías de 50 lugares para
explorar en este 2000 de la 22a los 50
mejores a destinos elegidos por la
revista 'time' y sus corresponsales
alrededor del mundo dice tan
persistentes como son a los retos para
la vida en este 2022 también es cierto
que ya digamos pasado lo más duro de la
pandemia es el momento para que la
humanidad reconecta y vuelve a compartir
y qué mejor forma dice que viajando por
el mundo sin embargo es una muy
destacable sé un poco digamos
problemáticos o contradictorios algunos
de los destinos que plantea por ejemplo
vamos a ver tres ejemplos que hemos
seleccionado
por un lado ahora lo vamos a ver aquí
detrás plantea una crucero por el ártico
116 días por el polo norte digamos
aprovechando prácticamente el deshielo
vemos esta imagen a la que sólo le
faltaría un oso polar puesto aquí encima
flotando encima del hielo para que nos
diéramos un poco cuenta de la situación
en el polo norte por otro lado también
destacar que este crucero que plantea la
revista vale de 30 mil dólares hacia
arriba viena por otro lado también
tenemos doha en qatar aprovechando dice
que se va a celebrar ahí en la mundial
de fútbol se han construido por lo menos
a 100 nuevos hoteles también cabe
destacar que en ningún momento del texto
que acompaña a este destino se cita la
explotación al laboral las condiciones
prácticamente de esclavitud moderna en
las que se han construido estas
infraestructuras están denunciadas por
organizaciones internacionales
viena por otro lado también hay que ver
qué pasa finalmente con estas
infraestructuras y terminar con el
destino de la espacial la estación
espacial internacional
propone también esta revista aparte del
precio que cuesta ir hasta ahí desde
20.000 hasta 55.000 dólares destacar
también lo problemático que es para el
medio ambiente esta promoción del
turismo espacial una problemática que no
mencionan en el texto eso sí vinculan
las palabras vuelos turísticos al
espacio con un artículo que se llama los
billion los billonarios corren al
espacio y el clima está pagando el
precio rosa como siempre muchísimas
gracias a lunes nos vemos con más
revista de prensa aquí en directo
américa saludamos a nuestra primera
mitad al día